arthur you're coming to live with me now
okay
that's the bathroom
this is the living room
this is the dining room where people
come and eat sometimes
look it's lonely out here so you better
learn how to talk with me
this is 2003. this is what the sun looks
like and the stars this is the president
and this is the sun in 1955 and the
stars and the president
my parents got married in 1955. they had
a child and they stayed married for 44
years until my mother died
six months later my father told me he
was gay i'm gay i remember him wearing a
purple sweater when he told me this but
actually he wore a robe i'm gay
he was gay the whole time they were
married
oliver
i just met a girl you point i'll drive
this one
hello oliver yeah they had some
wonderfully loud music in the club
tonight
what kind of music is that probably
house music house music
okay
house
house music
the bronchoscopy revealed a mass
well let's not rush out and tell
everyone
sometimes i wonder before anna i had
four serious relationships i let all of
them fall apart
just be happy about it
for the first time i saw him really in
love
and i am once again with you
people like us half of them think things
will never work out the other half
believe in magic and each kiss an
inspiration
sex
life
healing
nature
magic
the memory of love's refrain
this is what i'm supposed to feel like
yeah me too